call of duty advanced warfare is out
this week and it's set in the future but
it's all future thing a little overdone
at this point and what can we expect is
going to follow it up once upon a time
world war two shooters were all the rage
and then everybody moved into
present-day modern warfare now we're
seeing a pretty heavy shift in the wake
of games like titanfall Borderlands the
pre-sequel and destiny admittedly the
future is an awesome place to face off
against waves of enemies since it
enables cool sci-fi weapons like
titanfall smart pistol lots of robots
and imaginary and usually apocalyptic
futures which inevitably call upon you
to go save a bunch of stuff by shooting
a bunch of dudes Call of Duty advanced
warfare is taking itself to the not too
distant future that's about 40 years or
so and it actually should be pretty cool
in the scheme of the series since it's
set to bring a bunch of new things
there's a whole lot developer
sledgehammer games are promising to
deliver and try to give gamers in a new
Call of Duty and the futuristic setting
allows them to do that the franchise
which started off as a world war ii game
eventually became Call of Duty ghosts
which hinted at new technologies but for
the most part they all used similar
kinds of 20th century weapons now
sledgehammer are totally going for it
the year is 2050 for and private
military corporations and Kevin Spacey
dominating the Armed Forces as for
future tech Call of Duty advanced
warfare has things like a threat
detection grenade behind a wall and
discover where and how your enemies are
moving transport why there are hover
bikes and hover tanks which take you
over water and land just like in sweet
sci-fi movies if you like you can also
sink yourself to a mobile barricade
which is well a mobile barricade that
knows where you're moving and when you
want to shoot through it
speaking of shooting crap the game is
also leveraging its futuristic setting
with a bunch of new future guns
including directed-energy weapons which
are essentially death in the form of a
huge
theme think Mass Effect 2 epic collector
particle cannon you're also able to use
your exoskeleton to equip EXO abilities
and just generally be a bit of a cyborg
superhero jumping higher cloaking
yourself and adopting super strength to
punch people off ledges wow this is all
great the call of duty it's not
necessarily stuff we haven't seen before
as we move forward with shooters
advanced Warfare's futuristic features
can be seen as things which are becoming
commonplace sure there have always been
shooters set in the future but think
about recent games or LANs the pre
sequel which just came out and delivers
on a lot of hypothetical future tech as
you jump around and shoot people in low
gravity on the moon and let's not forget
titanfall whose giant controllable robot
suits and jetpack jumping but pointed
out when advanced warfare was revealed
then there's destiny and you all know
about destiny even the outcoming evolve
which we won't see until next year is
set in the distant future and sports a
bunch of unique high-tech weaponry
although the future where giant monsters
have humans is not necessarily a future
I want to live in given this trend it's
worth wondering whether the future
setting is genuinely a developer's
oyster in terms of what the setting
encourages and allows them to do when
creating a game that is how the
limitless nature of a hypothetical
setting can more easily lend itself to
an imaginative and innovative shooter
even so are we starting to see just a
bit too much of it are we oversaturated
with futuristic shooters what's next is
anybody's yes payday and battlefield are
going to cops and robbers roots well
what - shooters have come and gone and
the modern warfare shooters are probably
just about done zombie games have
miraculously stuck around but which way
will the futuristic games go this will
probably be out trend for a little while
longer but when will it be done
personally I think the appeal of
futuristic settings is always going to
be there but we should see the next
trend well on its way next year let me
know what you think of it and what you
want to see sure does tackle in terms of
a theme